As you know, Marty said that a lot of films made today are theme park rides. Marty what did you do...
Your Iron Man portrayal has become the thing it is a huge moneymaker. Yeah. You still enjoy doing it, yes?
It is this very large multi-headed Hydra at this point. According to Scorsese it's not cinema,
I got to take a look at that. But it is cinema, isn't it? I mean it plays in theaters.
I mean that's like saying, you know
money aint funny
Films are film. I think in his view were
Denigrated the the the art the era the art form of cinema. Going to the movies used to be an experience
people will go see movies just because they said is going to be number one. The value
How do you say the value of a film that's like a theme park film. For example, the Marvel type pictures
It's not cinema. It's something else and we need the theater owners to step up for that to allow theaters to show films that are
Narrative films he got a lot of heat for it, but I understand fully what you were saying
They always felt cut from the same cloth in that they were very big and event and CGI
Spectacles to some extent I was thinking at the time what would it be like to really strip it all down and do and do?
a really intimate
Character study or you explore one of these characters in an intense way. The Joker was inspired by your sin
I know but your movies, but do you also consider it as a theme park movie? I don't know about that
I know the film very well, and I know Todd very well might producer Emma Dillinger Cos Cob produced it
so
It's an interesting question
No one's left we're not laughing at the clouds, I don't want to be down on the clowns
We are colleagues in a certain sense comedians and clown comedians and clowns, but we all know somewhere underneath all of that bright color
There's a man who's not right? It's at some point. He's gotta wash his face taking his pants and start dealing with life like
Ladies gentlemen, say hello to the very talented Joaquin Phoenix
Thank you very much for being on the program again
You know
It's been three years since the last time you were on the show
And I will just say right off the top here you look different than I remember
Well that makes one of us
You've got a nice beard going and oh, yeah, how was that the beard?
In my way. I watched that whole interview and I said to myself Joaquin Phoenix is a fucking genius
That was like the greatest press parents I've ever seen in my life. We're terrific in the film. I really enjoyed your work
Thank you. Yeah
This how brilliant of you basically what he's doing is resisting every
Protocol of what it's like to be on a late-night talk show you had a piece of cardboard in your room
Any of the banter he didn't do any of that hey
David
Yeah
Yes, we can talk about he's a completely different kind of celebrity than I am by design of what he does
He's a fine actor. You have a tendency to make things up
You lie on talk shows every time I've ever seen you the time you see walking in Phoenix he's in a movie
Pretending to be somebody completely different and he's very good at it. So you can't tell what he's actually like
Bad news for Marvel fans looking to see what keeps Phoenix in the role of dr
Strange as word is the actor has dropped out of talks with a comic book giant
The 43 year old actor was reportedly the first choice to replace Ed Horton as the Hulk but passed on the opportunity
You've said in the past that you would do a comic-book movie if the right role came up
Why was this the right role for you? Because it was complex in a way that the other
movies that I
flirted with weren't
probably why ultimately
Said yes to the movies because I wasn't sure of what I felt about him. I like that space. I'm
I'm comfortable there. I don't need all the answers
It just seemed to me no matter what the character is that just sort of
You're going along the journey with that character. You may like the character you may not
It's just that you're interested in the character
This movie and what Todd Phillips is doing in it as a director and how it's being written is
So Scorsese at times it's it has so much taxi driver
Negative thoughts and so much king of comedy and this is how I see you introducing me
You could say something like this one small thing
Yeah when you bring me out
Can you introduce me as Joker at that time?
There were so many films and we wonder wonderful actors between these characters where we didn't really know fully understand what their?
Motivation was and we were okay with that
It was always to give off this kind of unsettling vibe of this guy who pretty much separated from everybody else even in this
Locker room space alone kind of not part of the group always tried to shoot Bob in a single frame on his shot
however
When you take other people we try to shoot past him and include him in their frames
We try to keep him separate from everybody else Larry and I really chose to shoot a ton of this really long lens
So you have that real shallow depth of field that you see in some of those old school
Movies dude, there was a 600 millimeter lens longest lens I try to do is really isolate him
I tried to isolate him from other people buddy around him completely soft focus and he's kind of floating through the city
when you make a movie about one person every other element becomes a character the music is suddenly a character and
Locations of suddenly a character. I want to shoot this scene against Columbus Circle
So we'd see the life receive the city. The city is like really a character in this movie, too
You know, we wanted this movie to feel like it could have come out in the summer of 1979 doing the commentary here now
I see this and I know it's a pretty pretty close sense of New York in the late 70s, you know
You know that scene where he's dancing in the bathroom is scripted as an entirely different scene the script I believe had us saying that
He was preparing in front of the mirror, and I was saying to him
I really think we need for you to speak in the mirror. Speak to yourself in America
He goes into this little rundown
Bathroom in a run-down park and he he's gonna wash his makeup off and hide the gun under a thing and we me and Joaquin
We're on the set and we just like my ass doesn't really feel like the Arthur we've been filming now for four or five weeks
It's just not him. It was the last week of shooting we were over scheduled five days
They were it was very difficult. And we said okay, we just gonna shoot this scene and lock the door
So our assistant director wouldn't get in so we sat around for 45 minutes
Well, you know the crews outside just thinking about other possibilities their ad was banging on the door. Come on
We got to get out of here. This is good. This is good
Wait, give me another minute they call the operator and tell the operator what we're doing. I just did start on foot
Yeah
that was sort of at his feet and in front of the mirror right in front of him and he started improvising it and it
Kept saying are you talking to me? I just started playing the score from off of my iPhone
And he started doing this dance and that was it and but he just kept he went on a roll you're talking to me
Talking to me
Go ahead and produce this film you'll pawn the hammer is the producer on it. Why did you decide not to produce?
Personal reasons I think for me also scheduling and primary mean quite honestly
Taxi driver and King of Comedy and last imitation of Christ knows what my fights you've got to start at the bottom
I know that's where I am at the bottom
I think comedy is a very weird film but it has a lot in common with taxi driver
Other stories about outsiders who want to be insiders. Hi Eliza, let's
see
Jela, good to see ya Jerry Oh get up. Hey, Marie. Thank you so much for having me on the show
It's been a life front view of mine
Juggler has a certain kind of arrogance and this need to become revered and adored he sees himself as
As a king in some way you're looking
To die and the question is I think for a filmmaker is you know, they always say you have to like your characters
I don't think Square says he likes this Rupert Pupkin
You don't give a shit about people like you Arthur and they really don't give a shit about people like me either
I had such mixed feelings about the character as I as I went through the script and
everybody that are including my family have a different reaction to the character into the movie and what it means and
Whether they sympathize or not
I think it's that I look at my whole life and I I see the awful terrible things in my life and
Turn it into something funny and used to think that my life was a tragedy
But now I realize
It's a fucking and that's what I like about the movie and it's not that Arctic
It's not telling you precisely what you should feel or when and I think that's rare in in movies
You said these are not Silla Gretel what is cinema I
Know I
know
You know when there's an author there and you know when it's personal and you know it you can feel it
You can feel it comes through
every moment
every shot every and the actors and every piece of it and it and it just doesn't miss you and I don't know that I
Can explain it better than that? Why can't I spend six months?
Talking about the movie before we shot the first frame in the movie
So all we did was collaborate and talk about ways to do scenes approaches to the character tone
talk about telling him how the movies gonna look now when you guys
Sit down and when you first receive a script for one of these things, but do they?
Consult with you do they discuss this with you? I think that phrase the legal phrase for actors and studios is meaningful consultation
Not script approval that reviewed dailies and I'd go through the script
So I just have like still have questions and so I would call him for two hours
We would talk like almost every night getting a pretty brutal
Education on what kind of process these movies require you just start trusting more that they're thinking on your behalf
It was exciting to me to see no matter how detailed and how well we wrote a script
For him to come in and make it his own that is literally what people mean
I think when they say the magic of movies
That's the magic part occasionally and in art you get lucky and you're at the right place at the right time with the right people
And I think that was the case with taxi driver
This is something that Schrader and Scorsese are learning from the French new-wave
From people like jean-luc Godard and Francois Truffaut. Oh and other filmmakers that were very very powerful influences at the time
there was grail inspired by the works of Martin Scorsese and Sidney Lumet and other
filmmakers that I sort of grew up worshipping in the 70s and early 80's every film that you make is a celebration of
filmmaking and
Part of that celebration is to allude to them to give a nod
Joker taxi driver in King of Comedy all had clear directorial visions complete creative control and a strong actor director
collaboration those ingredients made those movies great
and the ingredients don't require a big budget or fancy equipment if you have a vision and want to make your own film you have
All you need to get started and to help make that vision come to life
You can join Ryan boost class on making your own videos look like a movie on Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning community that offers membership with meaning through its classes on topics like filmmaking video editing or
Photography with so much to explore real projects to create and the support of fellow creatives
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real growth the first
500 of my subscribers to click the link in the description will get two free months of premium memberships so you can explore your creativity
That includes Ryan booths class plus thousands of others that give you the opportunity to learn and discover new things
Thanks to skill share for sponsoring this video and thanks to my patreon supporters for making this channel possible. Thanks for watching